but I really want to talk about this
lady who's attacking Elon Musk because
what she's proposed is the most it's
it's it's the most one of most insane
things I've ever heard
basically unions wanted to make sure
that everybody was working at the
company so that the Union could pressure
them to join the union because in
California for the most my understanding
is if you get hired to a company that's
Union you got to join the Union okay I
hate that and you have to pay union dues
and all that okay imagine imagine
getting a law passed where you can force
people to pay your organization hmm
that's messed up I hate it yeah if you
want the job you got to do it that may
not be true I don't I don't know exactly
if California has that law but a lot of
places do there's a lot of lawsuits
popping up where people are suing saying
I shouldn't have to join your Union to
work here okay and so I think they're
winning in some of these places but I
mean what why would it be I know it's
forcing anyone to do anything is the the
problem that you have with it right but
I was was going under the assumptions
that unions were good a good thing right
they protected your rights maybe a
hundred years maybe 70 80 years ago so
you don't think we need unions anymore
we do you collective bargaining unions
are messed up bad ok there are some good
unions for sure but like what it's
become is you get these I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna name some of these because
they're just they're just like shakedown
organizations that'll sue me if I say
their names but they go to media
companies they convince activists to
unionize not because they need
improvements to their benefits or
anything like that but to force all the
employees to pay those union dues every
month and then the union can claim we
just added you know 300 new subscribers
imagine if you could snap your fingers
and 300 people were giving you 50 bucks
a month or something it's great love
that money sounds pretty good and what
do they really do free try it where they
really do for you that's not working
so what we need is what we need is legit
unions yeah and that's that's the
challenge like how do you weed out the
corruption and the breakdown of the
system so the initial concept of unions
were like really really great you know
you had a bunch of really awful
conditions and all you'll get together
and engage in a collective bargaining
which is fantastic
yeah and I'm like I'll put it this way
I'm actually extremely Pro Union okay
but my concern is that a lot of the big
corporate you
are corrupt and they exploit companies
and try and hurt them and things like
that so you end up with people who don't
know what they're doing giving up their
rights let me tell you man I worked for
a company they forced me to join the
Union and then I couldn't move at all
within the company hmm it was like all
of my opportunity and all my rights were
gone because and and whenever I had a
problem I couldn't go to my boss I
couldn't go to supervisors and be like
yo I got a problem
they got union rep union rep nope get
out get out get out I can't talk to you
I can't talk to you about this I said
I'd have to go to a union rep and then
issue my grievance if I wanted to raise
go to a union rep and then the rep would
say what yeah yeah I don't know man you
know whatever sounds like well how do we
do the negotiations man they call my end
of the year come on bro I'm working so
you couldn't do already getting your
paycheck I don't care they don't care
that's what I heard here I know so like
the the issue I take with it is that it
got so big that instead of actually
defending the rights of people it just
defends the rights of the people who
line their pockets with gold we had
people who would run for executive board
they'd be making an extra twenty
thousand dollars a year because the
Union is is you know basically pays them
that sounds like nothing that sounds
like the problem with most positions of
power it's always the same thing
yup whoever gets to the power they're
like oh you know this power is pretty
good my bank accounts looking pretty
fantastic I don't really care about my
morals any more my bank account look at
my bag they never cared look at my bank
account though yeah that's not what's
important gotta take care me in my own
they would say that's it that's the
thing that's why I like for me running
these companies we were talking about I
don't know I don't know if we talked
about Genki or of The Young Turks yeah
we did
and he's like union-busting yeah those
hilarious nah you know it is it's funny
because he's supposed to be a
progressive my attitude is this
I'll give you honest advice I think the
problem with unions you know but if you
want to come to me and tell me I mean
you guys I'm gonna be like hey man you
do your thing like if you want to jump
into a well head first I don't care like
I'm not gonna stop you man I'm all about
freedom and liberty so you do what you
got to do and I just think it's
detrimental to the individuals okay a
lot of people don't get it
they don't get it you're giving up so
much to it it really depends it's the
point right it's like I was mentioning
it's it's corrupt organizations that
lock you down take your money and hold
you back
especially at you know
be honest like especially a couple of
the company like The Young Turks they're
not that big they're pretty big yeah but
I would I wouldn't want to be involved
what's what's pretty big like 30 50 cut
you know employees no time thunder
dozens oh they have a thousand no no
Young Turks probably has a hundred or
something over that yeah all right so
I'm saying yeah yeah they're not very
big so that's a kind of company where
you can walk up to jank and be like yo
here's what I need and here's what I
want mm-hmm you didn't gets involved you
can never do that again
I mean you probably could you know
because it's still not that big yeah
yeah but I'll tell you what man I've
been I've worked at companies that have
dealt with this stuff and it's like you
lose that freedom to shine they cut up
the tall grass tits it locks you down it
basically straps
everyone's ankles together which can be
a good thing for the people who can't
swim
so look I think about this way you got a
hundred people all in the ocean mm-hmm
you got 20 of them who can't swim 20 bum
who can swim really really well and the
rest of Everage you chain everyone
together and the really great swimmers
are being held down by everyone else and
the really bad swimmers are being held
up by everyone else okay I personally
don't want someone chained to my leg I
that sounds horrible that's how I view
it yeah that's my my view of it okay
well that's why I'm saying like if
someone came to me and they were like I
think we want to do this I'd be alike
go for it yeah I don't keep me out of it
yeah I mean that's why I run the comb
you know I run my company I don't I'm
not gonna that's that's a thing right
when I worked for these companies I was
straight-up like not I want to be
involved yeah but anyway go back to that
Lorena Gonzales woman the like the most
detrimental devastating thing about what
she ended up pushing with a b5 it's like
you have people who do writing for a
bunch of different outlets right okay
someone might be alike I write about
food for four you know food not food and
read about news for News News and I read
about sports for sports not sports okay
so you've got three clients that you let
you work for okay like basically it's
like you're a fruit vendor and every day
you have a company who says I will buy a
satchel of you know oranges and another
guy buys apples and the guy buys mangoes
because of this bill they've basically
said you can no longer deliver these
products to your customers so like what
do you do do you like form an LLC then
and now you're officially a company
providing deliverables they've basically
just said let's say let's say you have
three
websites you write for okay and a lot of
people did had multiple sites they were
writing for they all got the contract
severed because of this lady mm-hmm so
then what's the point now I have to beg
one of those companies to hire me and my
company gets shut down that's insane
that's empowering the big corporations
you know empowering venture capital
empowering big you know corrupt unions
it seems to be the way everything's
moving just Walmart's taking over
everything oh yeah dude I know Amazon
talking about the lockdown and what
Tesla is doing we are seeing a bunch of
small shops now defy the orders and like
Fu basically yeah because a local you
know like a local shoe store can't can't
be open Walmart no problem walmart sells
shoes yeah gardening's gardening
supplies closed Walmart open so there
was like a weird loophole where it's
like if you sell booze you can stay open
so you're like if you're a gardening
shop make sure you get a liquor license
and sell a small case of beer that way
you can't get shut down ever again it
doesn't make sense yeah but but the
bigger issue is that big-box stores
major corporations were basically immune
yep so all these lockdowns did was
empower massive conglomerates yeah sure
they made a killing man yeah well
they're losing a lot of money but it's
like they're not sinking every single
time I went into any store over the past
two months it was like Sam's Club or
Walmart I mean those are the few places
that were open mad people get full carts
every single person I saw was just
packed a packed card well because you
can't go anywhere else anymore exactly
so it used to be like yeah I'll go to
Walmart pick up some paper towels bread
milk and eggs right yeah now I'm gonna
go there and get shoes a new TV I'll
control it for my PlayStation so game
stops out you know they're already
struggling I mean I don't what they
can't believe Game Stop was actually
still around anyway yeah cuz we just
order stuff or the Best Buy and just
download my games but it's the small
businesses yeah you know that you know
people who did specialty jobs mm-hmm
that's what we're seeing it's the
weirdest thing to see this like a tribal
issue where it's like we want to destroy
small business and we want everyone to
work for someone else that's the
craziest thing yeah I don't get that if
you run your own company or fine well
let's get let's let's let's get
over to the next bit where it gets even
crazier talking about the lockdown
orders and all that stuff we have this
tweet from Bill maloo maloo GaN the LA
County Sheriff says video surveillance
shows inmates at a jail in in Cass Tech
sharing a water bottle then rubbing the
same masks on their faces to
purposefully infect themselves with
kovat 19 online because they thought it
would force their release 21 end up
infected well they got what they wanted
now could you imagine if they actually
arrested Elon Musk yeah they're not
gonna do it
but you know they're out there thinking
like some people watches well there was
there was one person that tweeted Wyatt
I'm serious there was one one person
tweeted like I agree arrest Elon Musk is
like a weird tribal thing Wow yeah
they're not going to but they did a
razor that salon owner and in Dallas
yeah and then they forced them to let
her go to mention from conservatives got
her out
you know people she made like five
hundred grand and a GoFundMe or
something good firm yeah yeah great
great so at the same time what did -
boys a boss I got it just say she was a
boss to that Judge but think about how
insane this is Dallas released like a
thousand a county jail inmates insane
because it was Dallas that she got a
rise up same so we talked about this
before what's going on the last time we
talked about this I was like I don't
think it's the same jurisdiction let's
be fair no it was it was Alice Dallas
released like a thousand jail inmates
and then put her in his embarrassing
that's insanity yeah alright that's
probably a better word thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you